it is time for hatred mail.
I will very quickly remind you what is hatred
mail,
because the government that is supposedly
totally inept is the same government that
can pull off a conspiracy that will blow your
mind.
Hey tread mail written by Patriots who hate
David Pakman because America and because freedom.
All right.
Sometimes hatred mail requires an introduction.
Sometimes Patriot male wants an introduction.
Neither is the case this week.
Let's just get right into it.
David Jew Pacman saying cringe and cringe.
Pacman just cannot help being a subversive
Jew.
It's in his blood.
Every time his videos pop up, I'm reminded
of how much of a fake and an elitist he is.
Playing drums, traveling to Europe, driving
a car in Boston.
David, always so naive and elitist.
Oh yeah.
David super delegates are bad.
Okays bad Jew.
His
is playing drums considered elitist.
I actually didn't know that.
I know Europe is certainly considered elitist
in American right-wing circles.
Anything European is elitist and a very beta,
uh, for people who, who think of the alpha
beta male paradigm, but just playing drums
is a, is a lead, is driving a car, is elitist.
Now, very strange.
I feel like the attacks are becoming more
and more flacid.
Uh, but I will remind you that you can use
the coupon code hatred 40 to save 40% off
of a membership@joinpacman.com and when you
use the coupon code hatred 40, the hatred
IOTs are miserable because they see that their
attacks are only growing support for independent
media.